in the 70s a young David Bowie asked is
there life on Mars and sadly we haven't
found any Marvin's or little green men
just yet but there are people like NASA
space X and the Mars one program working
to get us humans up to the red planet
say we did make it up there would it be
everything that movies like the Martian
promised would games like red faction
mass effect and of course do hold an
ounce of authenticity what would life on
Mars actually be like I figured I need
an expert for this one so I enlisted the
help of a man with possibly the best job
title I've ever heard president of the
Mars Society of Australia dr. John Clark
and I asked him how difficult would it
be for humans to live on the red planet
it would be quite challenging
difficulties always a matter of degree
people say our space is always hard well
everything's hard you don't know what
you're doing but if we know what the
issues are and we have the technology
and we've trained for it then it's
something that could be quite
straightforward which doesn't mean which
is not the same as saying it's easy all
right I expected that there's plenty of
reasons why life on Mars would be
difficult even getting there takes quite
a while NASA's current expeditions take
about six to eight months to reach Mars
and then when we get there it is super
cold I'm from the north of England and
it's pretty chilly there but on Mars the
temperature gets to about minus 80
degrees Fahrenheit or minus sixty-two
Celsius and then there's the matter of
the atmosphere according to NASA it's
about ninety-five percent carbon dioxide
and about one percent oxygen which is
quite a lot less than we're used to but
say we've got a big space suit and an o2
tank what steps need to be taken to
ensure our continued survival when we
set up stations on Mars research
stations exploration stations we will
need to provide the essentials from the
Martian environment and we know we can
do that the Martian atmosphere is very
thin but its carbon dioxide and we can
process carbon dioxide to
stract oxygen we know there's quite a
water on Mars largely in a form of ice
in the ground or hydrated minerals so we
can extract the water from the ground
and then from that we can produce
hydrogen and oxygen we can potentially
grow food there by making artificial
soil so there's a whole range of things
that are quite feasible that we can do
that would allow us to live long-term on
Mars hopefully what John saying here is
that we won't have to use poop for
potato fertilizer good news then
everyone theoretically speaking the best
kind of speaking we can survive on Mars
if and when the Mars one program works
and we establish human colonies up there
we can source our food and water locally
but there's one key difference between
Earth and Mars and that is gravity
Mars's gravity is about thirty eight
percent of Earth's so if you were to
drop something on the surface of Mars it
would fall a lot slower than if you were
to drop something on the surface of
Earth but that also means that things
weigh a lot less on Mars if you were to
weigh a hundred pounds on earth you'd
only way about 37 38 pounds on Mars
which means the carrying stuff is a lot
easier really fit soldiers infantry
soldiers can carry up to about 60 kilos
on earth but that's really pushing a
limit and they often have a lot of back
injuries strain injuries even stress
fractures as a result of that now on
Mars 60 kilos that you can carry in
weight would be more like 150 kilos on
Mars so that that's feasible of course
on the other on the other hand if we're
talking about futuristic military
scenarios maybe the armor that the
soldiers would wear might have some kind
of power source and be more like an
exoskeleton and then of course all all
bets are off see exoskeleton spacesuits
now we're getting with the video game
stuff so with all that in mind could we
try super jumping how high you jump will
depend of course on how much equipment
you carry and but you'll always be able
to jump further and higher than you
would on earth caring
same amount of mass because on earth we
see massive weight as being the same
thing but once we go to a place with
different gravity they're not so on the
moon yeah Paulo astronauts wearing over
120 kilograms of equipment and yet it
only seemed like 20k only weighed about
20 kilograms to them so even though
they're very encumbered they could move
around a lot more easily than they would
carrying the same amount of weight on
earth we could hardly move at all but of
course the tricky bit would when it
would be when you turn the corner
because of the inertia of the mass
you're carrying wouldn't change and so
if you're not careful you might need a
twist an ankle or break a leg or land
very awkwardly and of course every space
marine needs a gun to shoot but what
exactly would happen if you were to
shoot a gun on the surface of Mars well
it worked much the same as here but the
lower Martian gravity would be a major
factor so things so if you fire if you
fire a gun on earth you know the
projectile comes out of the barrel and
the moment it leaves a barrel it starts
dropping under gravity all other things
being equal the range is determined
mostly by the time it takes for that
projectile to fall from the height of
which it's fired to the ground all other
things being equal so if you angle of
the gun at her say 40 degrees will go a
lot further and if you fire horizontally
for that reason now a Mars gravity is
thirty-eight percent of us and so things
will further for more slowly I'll
accelerate more slowly and so you can
fire projectile weapons a lot further so
now we are not only is life on Mars
totally possible but it might actually
be viable within 10 or 20 years at least
that's according to the Mars one program
but still that is just crazy that's all
for this week do you think humans are
ready to colonize another planet be sure
to let me know in the comments below or
of course come find me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games thank you for watching
this episode of reality check for more
make sure you keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot com